over 170 people with Epstein links
likely to be named in court doc said to
be un unsealed in upcoming weeks and
let's see this here Manhattan federal
judge Loretta presca who needs hardcore
protection by the way has ordered the
release of long sealed court documents
in a defamation lawsuit filed by Jeffrey
Epsy accuser Virginia Roberts uh against
galain Maxwell in 2015 this decision
will likely lead to the identification
of 170 individuals asso with Epstein
some of whom have previously been
referred to as Jane does or John does in
court filing the this ruling the ruling
gives these individuals 14 days to
appeal and it mentions that some of them
have already spoken publicly about their
connections to Epstein either as former
employees or victims name of some of the
individuals involved such as these uh
those mentioned the Epstein little black
book are considered public figures so
interesting this judge could be a
billionaire in the next few weeks if if
she wanted to she needs protection um
all of these guys are talking to each
other right now saying what do we do I
wonder what Leon black is doing right
now maybe he needs some estate
planning EP and his lawyer better do
something about this or otherwise he
could get
killed yeah but you think they're
actually going to let because this is
like this is this is big this is big
because they're saying a bunch of the
people that were helping the victims the
stores everything's going to be start
coming out after the New Year well Jesse
Waters asked RFK and RFK said he was on
the play twice and it was with his wife
and his kids because his wife was
friends with galain and he came out and
said I want this thing to be public so
everybody knows about the flight I want
everybody to know who those names are go
ahead and do it yeah these are flights
to the island or just flights with himig
difference 170 people Epstein links to
be named what that means no one knows
because those are two different things I
mean and here's thing she makes a good
point because RFK supposedly was linked
to him because he was they were hitting
up for charitable donations and the
Kennedy foundation and that's rfk's
Point make it all public make it all out
there my wife were on the plane this guy
was a player moving money around for
Charities and for political purposes and
so twice I was own as playing with them
nothing to see here broadcast it put it
out there that's why I believe RFK on
that other people that don't want let's
put it this way if the plane was going
north and south from West Palm Beach to
New York and it was charitable and it
was at the same time they're doing the
Kennedy Center you know uh fundraisers
and stuff okay but if you're on the
plane that's going east and west you
probably have some problems yeah you got
something to hide you have something to
hide it doesn't well it doesn't help
when Dick Durban is trying to block
subpoena to find out like here's the
thing Name by way protect the pedophiles
yeah dick der hey Adam what happened
last week I got dick deran but listen my
point is didn't mark wber play him but
by the way this has been going on for
how long we have gilay Maxwell the fact
that not everything is out in the open
cuz listen explain yourself I could see
Tom before he got like arrested and you
know people now know that he's a
pedophile and he's a sex trafficker if
you were flying there to the island
after like you got to explain yourself
you know he's a pedophile you know he's
arrested for for trafficking kids why
are you going there Bill point because
went a 93 is when he said his flight
Records Was 93 before any of this was
public I think we just need to
understand that we that we can't just
basically make people guilty before
they've been proven innocent or do a new
new trend in America of course my point
because we want to make everybody guilty
and then just say if you've been on a
flight with Epstein or even been to his
Island then you should go to jail well
you know who's going to jail Donald
Trump Bill clintoned Allan Greenspan RFK
so it's Nuance because a lot of these
people were probably blackmailed by
Epstein right we've done the Playbook
where like hey you come have a good time
everything record by the way then he's
like but you know therea in the bathro
camera in your bedroom there's a camera
so a lot of it was a setup trying to
Hatchet job something like that so it
does take some Nuance but any who just
was on a plane with Epstein isn't guilty
of anything what did they do on that
island is that thing we need to find out
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here